Người bà mệt tháng năm, ngân hàng nhấn nước Việt Nam chính thức công bộ kết lận thành tra việc chấp hành chính sách,
pháp lật trong khoản động kinh dân văn tại các dân nghiệp vàng hành.
Du vình lớn đơn vị chấp hành cơ bản quy định pháp lật,
cơ quan thành tra vẫn phát hiện nhiều xe phạm nghiêm trọng.
Cũng thế, công typ biển trời bị sự phát hơn một phẩy bà tỷ đồng gió vì phạm quy định của pháp lật
về chế độ thông tin bảo cao mua, bán vàng miếng và hạt động phòng, chống dự tiền.
Công tyddo gì bị chỉ gió vì phạm về chấp hành chế độ bảo cao hạt động kinh dân mua,
bán vàng miếng, một số sâu dịch bán vàng với giá bán cao hơn giá nghiêm ít.
Về hạt động kinh dân vàng khác, hạt động vây vốn bằng vàng của vinh dân,
khách hàng và hạt động giữ hộ vàng miếng trên ứng dụng íg gâu, khi chưa được cấp có thưởng quyền cho phép.
Tương tự bảo tin miếng châu vì phạm nhiều quy định trong thương mại nịch tự như đã không công bố trên quép xài bê tê mở xe chấm viên thông tin công khai về vận chuyển và rau nhận.
Trên nhiệm sự lý hiểu nại của khách hàng không xe dựng chính sách bảo vệ giữ liệu cá nhân người tiêu dùng.
Đăng chú ý, một số ngăn hẳng bị phát hiện thao túng xo dịch bán,
tạo xe số ảo thương qua việc không xo nhận bán, chỉ thực hiện xo dịch phần chính lịch giá.
Nếu tổ chức cũng chưa tôn tụ quy định về phòng chống dự tiền, không bảo cao xo dịch lớn và không đạo tạo nhất sự theo quy định.